was geht ab es war marks und herzlich
willkommen zu diesem neuen video
ich werde heute mal etwas machen was sie
bisher noch nie in der form gemacht habe
und zwar gucke ich mir ein altes video
von mir an und zwar das video wo ich
mich zum aller ersten mal gezeigt habe
auf youtube das muss man sagen dass ich
eigentlich bisschen kritisch gegenüber
solchen videos bin aber es ist wirklich
lustig weil ich erinnere mich noch an
das video ich habe es mir wie vor ein
paar monaten irgendwie mal angeschaut
werden das war wirklich relativ ja
lustig wie ich da so aufgetreten bin und
wie auch kokosnuss an ok erstmal
wunderschöne optik hier zehntel
krankhafter zeigt sind wird noch diese
minen darin sehr nice und starten wir
leute nach dem intro seht ihr wie im
echten leben auch sehr diese mikrofon
qualifiziert dabei
ja das war mein intro position meine
freunde hallo und herzlich willkommen
zum ersten facetime video auf einem
kanal
ich bin markus frank reiter violine mich
nennen wollte man rückläufige okay das
ist jetzt am 4.9 2013 gewesen das heißt
es über zwei jahre her
dort wirklich krass meine haare waren
deutlich länger und ich war wirklich
sehr schwierig darüber gehört aber sie
vor allen dingen klassiker ist diese
overberg musik im hintergrund die jeder
drin hatte immer weiter ich habe da ich
nehme das facetime video das video wo
ich mich auch gleichzeitig als anlass zu
ein paar sachen über mich lustig werden
so ein paar persönliche sachen die man
halt super wissen könnte über mich halt
in verbindungen verbund mit facetime
sache dass jetzt wisst wie ich aussehe
ok also der krasseste unterschied zu
heute ist na gut ich fass mir die haare
wie man sieht macht ja auch heute noch
der krasseste unterschied ist einfach
das auftreten weil heute ist man
irgendwie nicht nachdem man es möglich
zwei jahre gemacht alter wie verrückt
man tritt schon wesentlich
selbstsicherer auf und das ist heftig
finde ich irgendwie also keine ahnung ob
ich mal gespannt was ich für persönliche
dinge bekannt gebe zu dem ersten live
videos gemacht habe also mein name ist
max
das dürften die meisten schon wissen ich
bin 16 jahre alt ja sehr alt krass
welche eltern aus leute nein ich halte
mich gut
okay das wäre auch schlimm wenn ich
freitags sehen will hat eine freundin
hat es gesehen da die sportfreunde nicht
verändert
apa oder war diese school story pro bild
eingebildet eingeblendet ist auf jeden
fall cool wäre ich war schon immer ein
bett
wir sagen wir gestalten das so ein
bisschen wie so eine kennenlernrunde in
der schule wie so eine kennenlernrunde
in der schule leichter resümierte rede
hörte musste vollidiot also wirklich
voll cool fühlen
ich will sagen wir gestalten das so ein
bisschen wie so eine kennenlernrunde in
der schule dass ich bin mal schlagen das
erzählt in dem fall
das ist keine runde naja ich lade
einfach ein bisschen vor mich hin so
freizeitmäßig in letzter zeit des todes
4 you tube und minecraft weil spot macht
und weil man weil ich jetzt halt
den youtube-kanal habe den hier
anscheinend alle kennt wenn ihr das
video scharf gemacht sind
was hat mega rock macht und am anfang
vor allem wenn man diese youtube sache
einsteigen müssen viel zeit investieren
so kontakte knüpfen
videos machen bearbeiten das alles
erlernen tage vor allen dingen gleich
mal leute ich habe damals meine videos
vor allem schon nicht groß bearbeitet
mittlerweile mache ich jetzt selten aber
wirklich was ich damals in die videos
gesteckt habe ihr seht sie an dem video
ist waren gefährlich also so schön frech
den blick weiter letzter zeit viel zeit
reingesteckt und ansonsten
longboard ich in meiner freizeit zu
sehen ist auch ungespielt simon macht
nahe und schadet so sachen halt dann mit
kumpels treffen wurde meiner freundin
oder so und das sind die sachen knapp
das habe ich damals sehr gefeiert habe
sie in den vordergrund gestellt wie ich
so zu dem kanal gefunden habe
dürftet ihr wissen vor allen dingen so
ich finde die art wie ich rede und so
klingt einfach so als würde ich so ein
richtig schweres geständnis ablegen bei
der polizei so von wegen wie ich zum
kanal gefunden habe das ist irgendwie
voll keine ahnung irgendwie so gar nicht
freundlich und motiviert kein hahn war
mit luca den habe ich im urlaub
kennengelernt und der das schon seit
einer ewigkeit gemacht und dann haben
wir zusammen gezuckt hieß blabla wie vor
als in den ersten videos von mir sehen
oder ich wollte einfach noch mal danke
sagen für 10.000 menschen die die
abonniert haben 10.000 einfach so
richtig gras viele freunde bei mir war
es hat heftig ich hatte so schnell die
10.000 am anfang durch den support von
luca weil wir müssen überlegen sind
10.000 menschen in meiner schule
ich bin am gymnasium übrigens sind
10.000 menschen
was hab ich 2000 menschen
was machen warum hab ich damit hier
keine karte
also ja okay und 10.000 habe ich nie
verstehen das fünffache und mit den
allen dingen keine ahnung auf einem
fleck zu sein also das war schon krass
war 10.000 menschen man denkt zu wenn
man diese anderen leute sieht di luca
zum beispiel oder seine community das
10.000 nicht sind aber 10.000 einfach so
krass viele und ich finds mehr als
10.000 leute hier
entschieden haben dass main kanal so ist
das hier abonnieren wollen und wie sie
es eigentlich
ich finde also wirklich was mir am
krassesten stört es einfach wie ich rede
dass er die anders machen sollen vor
allem da oben ist mein zimmer noch grün
ich hab das mittlerweile weiß gestrichen
weil ich das megahertz und fand wie viel
hat muss natürlich oder ich glaube so
200.000 oder sowas umdrehen alle videos
gucken wir jeden fall dankeschön dafür
und als belohnung jetzt wie angekündigt
bei 10.000 bzw
in richtung 15.000 vier dass facetime
video und welche sagen schreibt einfach
in die kommentare was ihr euch jetzt
denkt nachdem ihr das fähigkeit video
gesehen habe wie groß ist sein penis die
große bühne wie groß ist sein penis
wurde
warum sagen nicht dass wie groß ist sein
penis oder sowas das wasser jetzt halt
zu ende gedachten kommt vor allen dingen
ich immerhin so die ganze zeit voll
trocken und dann rockig einfach die jörg
braun weiter
jetzt schreibt man die kommentare was
ihr so wissen wollt so zum beispiel die
große zu empfehlen ist die ganze zeit
trocken 10 sekunden und dann kommentare
freunde
selbst aktiv in den kommentaren las was
darf sagen vielen dank fürs zuschauen
haut rein und ich werde es jetzt
parallel beenden was gute alte richtige
pro oder contra das nächste video
arbeitsverhältnis jetzt nicht mehr
anschauen
wir gucken uns lieber ein paar
kommentare an max genau hier von dem hab
ich übrigens die video.de und der gute
mann wollte vor silvester noch 220
packen deshalb jack ma sein zeug aus
wenn es euch gefällt von denen hier mal
abonnieren sein linke ist in der
beschreibung
ok dann aussehen so schön danke schön
aber das sind die ganz das sind alles
die älteren kommentare der of crime vor
einem jahr haben die geschrieben diese
alten zeiten
ich will jetzt ein paar meter
dargestellt man meint du bist kein bruch
oder hast du dir die hardware ja stimmt
das haben wir damals alle geschrieben
dass ich genauso aussehen wie luca okay
nur deinen augenbrauen sind dicker ist
das gut oder schlecht wäre wenn ich von
conny conny sie auf watch alle schreiben
das tanken kraft der kraft schöpfen
du bist überall hübschen wtf sogar ein
wenig zurück oder tja leute hält spatzen
halte es hat glaube ich ja krank apples
mega projekt als ganzes megaprojekt wie
cool bisschen mit conny verwandt was
mein video mit deiner freunde bisschen
zu spät für den video zu machen
seine zu schüchtern du hast keinen grund
dafür ja standards erkannt ich bin voll
schüchtern und danke zwei jahre zu spät
ja leute also ich glaube die meisten
leute schreiben dass ich aussehe wie con
crafter ich hoffe mal das video gefallen
und wir sehen uns dann bei einem
normalen video wieder das weiß mal so
ein kleines experiment ich fand's
relativ cool muss ich sagen ich hoffe
ihr auch und da sehen wir uns einfach
morgen wieder seit aktiv und schreibt
die kommentare wie groß hier
nee nee so was machen